you've interviewed every I mean just
massive celebrities as an Obama Sir Paul
McCartney mess levees on the podcast
congratulations on that
do you ever anymore is it possible for
you to get starstruck or at this point
you like and I've met everybody
sometimes like will you interview people
too but like it was funny I did I the
Paul McCartney one hasn't gone up yet
yeah I had to do it live when I was
backstage right after I'm right after
like I met him yeah I looked at and I
said I hear the Beatles are off limits
yeah laughs because what else is he
gonna any way but they answer your
question I like seeing I still enjoy
seeing celebrities in the wild you know
like yeah when they're out doing their
life and just being hating like they're
ordinary people like reason when I was
in New Haven not important to the story
but if you know New Haven you can
picture it sure as at a restaurant
eating dinner with my girlfriend and
there's an older couple just like 10
feet away I didn't take notice initially
as we're eating I'm looking over at the
dude I'm like I know that guy who is
that guy and I realized it's the guy I
see sitting next to Meryl Streep at
award shows I recognized Meryl Streep's
nameless husband I'm sure he does not
the name but yeah what do I know but
first I think much respect I think I
should have told him because how often
does he get that okay and then she was
there so yes she was there but like I
saw him first so I I think I should have
told him like I don't know what you do
but I recognized you first I don't know
how often you get that but I you're very
good at sitting next to her well-dressed
while she wins stuff
thank you but but yeah it was it was
Meryl Streep yeah she was like like I
don't know why I'm looking there but I'm
picturing her at a table right there
just eating like a piece of bread with
cheese on it yeah girl Street yeah just
just eating bread with cheese on sure
yeah
and I gotta be honest with you just
brilliant the craft round 3 minute yeah
let's take a quick break much more with
Marc Maron his head cigarette
you